just attack fear wherever you see it
there should be no fear overcome a fear
one success model the best
what's up believe nation at seven I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so today let's learn one
of the most common rules that successful
people follow conquer your fears also if
you want to know what Warren Buffett
myself Will Smith and others have to say
about building confidence and excellence
check out my 254 series where every day
for the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help start
your day the links to join are in the
description below it's important to
associate with people who are better
than yourself surround yourself with
greatness if you want to be more
confident you need to surround yourself
with things that make you feel confident
it takes such a desperate obsessive
focus to to excel on a certain on the
level that I want to make movies
[Music]
we not just bungee jumping on a
helicopter
we're gonna do it at the grand can and
when I was up there and and I jumped I
realized you know it's fun and it's
exciting and there's something
mythological about confronting death
right because as much as we're laughing
at as much as we're having fun it really
is the emotional confront with death you
know and I'm 50 years old now
and I'm sort of having the realization
that you you you have to be able to go
[Music]
you have to be able to take that shot at
the thing that you dream you have to be
able to take that shot at that that love
that you want but that life that you
want to build and it's like you know
when I was up there and the guys said to
me the only way you can get hurt is if
you don't get away from the chopper
right and he said in that moment he said
we're gonna let the courts go of these
courts weigh 200 pounds right so when we
let him go they're gone the hesitation
is the thing that really messes up the
chance at having your dreams right get
out of the middle
push it off is sure frickin terror is
the moment of falling with you guys so
it's really not you can do just like
light there's nothing to hold on to and
we're all trying to hold on to something
you're trying to hold on to an idea or
you're trying to hold on to a person and
there's nothing to hold on to and we
gotta just get comfortable
falling knowing there's nothing to hit
right you know and that's the idea it's
like life is dangerous and the only way
to really enjoy is jump and be free I
never my life you know and every time
I'm cast in a film I am equally as
terrified as I was about the challenge
when I did my first fell in 17 and when
I did Titanic and when I did it turn on
sometime of the spotless mind and when I
did the reader you know that fear I
think is what drives me to be honest you
know acting it's such a wonderful thing
to do and I I love it and I and I love
it more as I'm getting older I think but
it is scary because you can easily get
it wrong somebody once said that the
chains of heaven are too light to be
felt until they're too heavy to be
broken I had been terrified of public
speaking
and throw up and I know if I didn't cure
it then they never cured
and so I saw an ad in the paper for the
Dale Carnegie course which worked on
developing your ability to speak in
public and I went down there be thin a
good mile as the thing that thick as a
puppy feel whatever weight they made it
to all these crazy things to get out of
ourselves and so we stood on tables and
did all kinds of things
[Applause]
[Music]
if I hadn't have done that my whole life
would have been different
so in my office you will not see the
degree I got from the University of
Nebraska you'll not see the master's
degree from Columbia University but
you'll see the board certificate I got
from the Dale Carnegie course it seems
like you can't open a book or read a
blog post these days without hearing
somebody tell you to follow your passion
or follow your bliss or follow your
heart and yes I have said those things
too
but today I want to talk about the power
of going in what can often feel like the
opposite direction I want to talk about
the power of following your fear I'm not
talking about following you're very
useful fear of big moving vehicles and
walking in front of a bus nor am I
talking about doing anything stupid or
irresponsible that could ruin you
financially what I am talking about
though is the power of following good
fear directive fear the kind of fear
that you feel when you have an idea that
just won't leave you alone an idea about
doing something that you've always
wanted to do something that's different
and bold and kind of risky where part of
you saying oh no I actually couldn't do
that but the deeper wiser part of you
wants this thing so damn bad and the
moment you imagine yourself going for it
you have worries like you know will
people laugh at me will they ignore me
maybe this isn't even really an idea
what if I do it and it sucks
am I gonna destroy my reputation am I
gonna lose my marriage and my family and
wind up living on the streets my friend
Steven Pressfield talks about this kind
of fear in the war of art and he says
remember our rule of thumb the more
scared we are of a work or calling the
more sure we can be that we have to do
it and he continues the more fear we
feel about a specific enterprise the
more certain we can be that that
enterprise is important to us and the
growth of our soul
don't know what will happen now we've
got some difficult days ahead but there
isn't a matter with me now because I've
been to the mountaintop
like anybody I would like to live a long
life longevity has its place but I'm not
concerned about that now I just want to
do God's will and I see the promised
land
about anything I'm not fearing any man
I've seen
also just attack fear wherever you see
it even when it's trivial even when it's
some kind of we were just before the
before we got on here we talked about
the fear of the number 13 trig a trick a
phobia like if you're afraid of 13 you
know what you need to do you need to put
13s all over your house you know you
need to like sit in 13s you need to go
to the 13th demand to be on the 13th
floor of every hotel in every airplane
because you got to get over that because
that is telling yourself that there's
something irrational that should control
you and if you believe there's something
that's a rational that should control
you that will apply universally so
wherever you find fear specifically
that's out of balance with actual danger
like I'm not saying touch a hot stove or
put your hand in a rattlesnake cage like
there's danger there that's not fear but
13 no danger you know that's not real so
go collapse that if there's a fear of
crickets like I have a fear of like
whatever it is collapse fear wherever
you see it and that specific collapse
will help with the universal collapse of
fear in general everybody says they want
to be the boss but people be standing a
divorce most people are scared to put up
their own money most people are scared
to tell people to work when they don't
want to most people are scared to even
ask for the money you know what I'm
saying like people I've seen people that
are uncomfortable about asking about
their own business like asking for
change get paid or when am I going to
get paid or where's my money I have
never felt uncomfortable about asking
for my bread I've never understood
people that were uncomfortable for
asking for their bread and I really
don't understand people that are
offended by you asking for your bread
you ask somebody
like what you asked you'd like I'm not
supposed to ask for my money am I
supposed to ask about my money like the
money and the business dissing with
asking about it because it's business
there should be no fear you should never
be ashamed to ask for your change ever
you know it's a scrutinized bill fear is
normal it's part of what makes you human
you would not be human or you'd have
some crazy condition if you never felt
fear I think the people who say don't be
afraid aren't giving you practical
advice it's be afraid feel the fear and
then step into it and do it anyway and
the more you get used to taking on those
fearful projects that you're scared of
the stronger you'll get the more
resistance you'll get the higher
tolerance you'll get to do bigger better
bolder badder things I think the trick
though is spotting the fear here's what
I think happens to most people there's
some opportunity that comes along
there's some moment that comes along
with this with a client or meeting
somebody or an event something comes
along that you're afraid of you're
afraid of doing it it's gonna stretch
you beyond what you've ever done before
and then what you do is you rationalize
saying no I don't have the money to go
to that event I'm too busy to go and do
that thing right now you find the reason
why you can't go and do it you
rationalize it but really deep down the
reason is you're just afraid and until
you spot the fear until you understand
that it's really just the fear then
you're never gonna solve the problem so
step one is understanding when there is
fear step two is then stepping into it
and doing it anyway and a lot of this
stuff is just so subconscious you know
we as human beings are kind of trained
to when we're afraid something's gonna
go wrong and to be safe and so it's
trying to catch that subconscious action
and proactively change it so it's an
example for me when I was starting my
youtube channel my agent would tell me
you have to go out and do videos in
public I want you to go in on the street
I make your video in public my natural
reaction was fear but I didn't catch it
initially it was
the gear won't be as good in public you
know I can't control the light settings
I'm gonna be bouncing around with the
camera it's not gonna be a great
experience for the people watching why
would I do that
I'm rationalizing a reason why I don't
have to do it we're really I'm just
afraid right you could solve all those
problems and he told me stop being
afraid and just go and do it he got
through it
and let me see my own fear and so I did
it and when I first went out and filmed
in public I took out it was my phone or
my camera I don't remember and I'm
walking on the street and then the
postman is there as soon as I see the
postman I quiet down and I can put the
camera away
just walking normally and then when the
postman leaves I'm back to filming and
that time I noticed like I'm doing it
because I'm afraid and I got pissed okay
next time I got a Speak Up next time I
gotta do better and so I went out and
forced myself to go and do it again and
I was walking past and there were these
construction workers and instantly again
the the panic sets in like people are
watching the construction workers like
oh they don't really even care about me
what I'm saying what's happening on the
street but I forced myself through it it
was awkward it wasn't great I think I
had to redo it again anyway but I I took
the step I got better at it I recognized
the fear and I jumped into it and now
it's to the point where I'll make videos
walking down the hall I make videos when
I'm at Disneyland
Disney World you know I'll make videos
in the streets of anywhere and there's
still a moment even now after how many
videos I've done there's still a moment
of who's watching I think it's natural
normal it's not as strong as it used to
be and more importantly it doesn't limit
me from doing the things that I want to
do and so spotting the fear and not
rationalizing it away and not just doing
what your subconscious always does that
keeps you down where you are is so
important being truthful that the reason
why you said no or you're not taking
this opportunities just because you're
afraid and the answer to say no should
never be
because I'm afraid you want to reject
your system so whenever that's the
answer because I'm afraid to do it now
you have to do it when you focus on the
worst possible outcome you actually feel
as if you want in that worst possible
outcome the only way to overcome a fear
is that of focusing on the worst
possible outcome to focus on the best
possible outcome I'm driving it's foggy
it's dark it's icy I might skid off the
road and kill myself or I'm driving very
carefully I'm driving very slowly I'm
driving very cautiously because I'm
going to be safe and I'm gonna get home
you see that's the difference you just
have to give yourself different beliefs
the thing with fear always is you have
two choices rationalize where you feel
so terrible or talk yourself out be nice
on the beach with my daughter and there
was a big dog and it was quite a scary
dog and she wouldn't like this dog and I
said to be no darling when you don't
like a dog you get very scared and the
dog doesn't like it either and he gets
scared so when you see a scary dog turn
your back to it don't look at it because
when you look at it you're challenging
it and that's hard to do to turn your
back on a dog but if you turn your back
it's not a challenge and she understood
that and I was always teaching it when
you have a fear you have a choice oh my
god that dogs gonna bite me attack me
hurt me or I'm gonna talk myself I'm
gonna turn away and abri they're gonna
be really calm and that dogs are gonna
go on its way and it's the same with
everything in life to do with fear
rationalize why you feel so fearful or
talk yourself out of it I'll be fine
this is okay everything's gonna work out
perfect
I'm okay all of these fears hold you
back and they don't have to because
every fear you go through teaches you
something you see if you go to a funfair
go to those loop-the-loop rides you can
scream in terror or you can scream in
excitement and the fact that we will put
themselves through those rides means
that at some level we quite like fear it
challenges us to do more it challenges
us to grow more so don't fear fear
remember the only fear to fear is fear
itself
as a young boy I was enthralled by
airplanes and the wonder of whether I
would ever embark on a flight that would
carry me to new exciting adventures and
a life of limitless possibilities I came
to know I had the power within me to
soar and that has made all the
difference in my life flying for the
first time is a lot like creating your
own business launching a start-up or
establishing a non-for-profit
organization both require a leap of
faith and a willingness to take a
journey of unexpected variables in other
words both require a little bit of crazy
and a whole lot of courage don't let
fear hold you back from doing what you
truly love commit to your visa and be
the CEO of your future
now got a really special bonus clip with
Grant Cardone on how to get out of the
fear that I think you're gonna really
enjoy but before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions time to
move from just watching another video
into actually taking action and if
you're feeling bold leave your answers
in the comments below here we go
question number one what fear is holding
you back number two how will you jump
into it and be free and number three how
will you celebrate after you've jumped
if you guys look around man it would
appear to me that 99% of the people that
you run into today or having some kind
of financial problem
Oh 76 percent of Americans live paycheck
to paycheck I know people that don't
live paycheck to paycheck that worry
about money every second of every day
when my dad died I didn't know anything
about the 1% but I knew I wanted to get
in that Club
I'm like I have to get above whatever
this middle-class thing is because
there's no safety here it's constant
fear I've only wanted money for one
reason to be out of fear so I could help
out so I could give to charity so I
could help my brother so I didn't have
to worry about how much the fuel costs
or do I run an ad budget or not man you
guys got to get out of the fear man
that's the whole purpose okay the fear
by the way is not a conspiracy this is
real everybody like Oh fear ain't real
yeah well uh huh that's easy for you to
say you ain't got any this second okay
because it ain't scary to write a damn
quote or to post something on Instagram
that's bein scary what's scary is going
to take a loan for sixty million dollars
see if you ain't got a little bit of
scare okay so you know to a customer hey
man you're wrong
okay my sip my daughter told me that day
customers robberies right papa no
they're not no they're not and most
people don't even know how to tell a
customer they're all okay best customers
I have I told no that's not true that's
not right
you're wrong and I'll show you up if you
want to learn more how Will Smith
conquers his fears check the video right
there next to me it's inspiring I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there skydiving is a really
interesting confront with fear right so
so I got I got a stand up